des sapeurs-pompiers blinois distingués
pour leurs récentes actions notamment
pour avoir aidé à sauver le beffroi nord
de notre dame de paris
il y a quelques années le conseil
départemental des yvelines avait fait
l'acquisition de deux bras élévateur de
46 mètres de haut
une aide précieuse le 15 avril dernier
dans la capitale dire notre fierté et
dire aux yvelinois peut être fier votre
argent a été bien utilisé
ça a coûté paris vinoy 70 centimes
d'euro
voyez cet argent
heureusement qu'on a dépensé 57
sapeurs-pompiers vie n'en ont reçu une
médaille
c'est le cas de la dudh ans steve venot
il est resté plus de sept heures dans
une nacelle pour lutter contre l'
incendie de notre dame de paris
on a eu une action plus qu'efficace
ce soir là donc on est assez fiers c'est
déjà dans la venue parce que dans une
carrière de pompier je pense que on
frappa interventions majeures aussi
importante
assez souvent on est fière aussi d'avoir
préservé
cette structure ce bâtiment car ça fait
partie de notre histoire c'est un peu
demain imaginer versailles son château
on n'imagine pas lors de cette cérémonie
un hommage a également été rendu aux
sapeurs pompiers mobilisés le 25 février
dernier lors de la rupture du pipeline à
auteuil et boissy sans avoir
j'ai été engagé l'après midi
effectivement pour coordonner les
opérations de pompage
suite à la rupture du 'pipeline' ça fait
40 ans je suis sapeur pompier c'est la
première fois que j'intervenais sur une
rupture de bail très fier pour le centre
de secours et puis très fier pour
à titre personnel bien sûr c'est
toujours une fierté de recevoir une
médaille
au total près de 4000 personnes au sein
du service départemental d'incendié et
de secours oeuvre au quotidien pour la
sécurité des yvelinois